did the latest modern horror classic
just hit screens reviews are in for talk
to me and its reception is reminding
people of a legendary film five decades
at senior horror is all the rage in 2023
from the Gory chaotic slasher Scream 6
to the cheeky viral sci-fi thriller
Megan it's undeniable that the genre is
having an excellent year however fans
have had to wait until late July for the
release of what might just be the
scariest movie of the Year a24s talk to
me directed by the filipo brothers talk
to me follows a group of young friends
as they figure out a way to conjure up
Spirits before long typical horror
Antics ensue what makes talk to me stand
out in a sea of supernatural horror
projects is how it leaves audiences not
just entertained but truly terrified
looper's own Aleister Ryder was
enthusiastic about the film giving it an
8 out of 10 rating and writing with
their directorial debut talk to me twin
brothers Danny and Michael Filippo have
done this seemingly impossible creating
an unsettling story with the air of an
urban legend without divorcing
themselves from the lived-in reality of
gen Z critics aren't the only ones
impressed with talk to me as kojo
director Danny Filippo told Yahoo
entertainment that audience members have
also had strong reactions he recalled
that some viewers even fainted during
their screenings saying it's happened in
some of the screenings one of the scenes
is a bit intense so people have been
reacting fainting while it may seem
far-fetched to believe that a film could
elicit such a strong response those who
have seen talk to me will attest to how
effectively it builds up dread and
tension for the Filippo Brothers the
positive reaction their cinematic debut
has received is overwhelming Michael
Filippo described the experience as a
Non-Stop dream to the guardian
expressing particular excitement that
esteemed filmmaker Guillermo del Toro
tweeted about the movie
what did the hand feel like
felt amazing despite how surreal the
filmmakers find its reception the
positive reactions for talk to me are
unsurprising considering their debut is
making a genuine impression on viewers
around the world on social media fans
have talked to me are singing its
Praises warning others about just how
horrific it is one Reddit user observed
that the last time they felt this
uncomfortable during a movie was
watching the fellow Acclaim day 24
horror hereditary fans on the horror
subreddit were also enthusiastic about
talk to me with one user writing they
used The Possession genre in a uniquely
smart way that really surprised me and I
don't think I've seen possession used
with such emotional depth since the
Exorcist the comparison to The Exorcist
shouldn't be surprising as the directors
behind talk to me have explicitly
mentioned the 1973 picture as an
influence speaking to Roger ebert.com
Danny Filippo reflected it's so obvious
but the Exorcist is such a powerful film
and grounded in such reality that
everything has such weight to it the way
they react to each situation is credible
I bought those characters I love realism
and horror and the way those horror
scenes have The Exorcist is one of them
most recognizable and influential horror
films of all time and it looks like talk
to me is taking a page from its director
William friedkin's book in more ways
than one at this point The Exorcist is
the stuff of Legends the film which
debuted in the winter of 1973 emerged as
a cultural phenomenon the movie tells
the story of a mother who enlists the
help of two priests to perform an
exorcism on her daughter as she exhibits
signs of possession at the time of its
release The Exorcist was a must-see
event compelling viewers from far and
wide to head to their local Multiplex to
catch the supernatural Thriller much
like talk to me reports begin emerging
that several people had fainted while
watching it news broadcasts from the 70s
showed several individuals walking out
of The Exorcist professing just how bone
chilling the film was with others flat
out fainting in the theater testimony
from theater employees only added to the
legend one employee reflected I've never
in my life known a movie where people
would faint it's hard to make people
faint while there are several reports of
The Exorcist terrifying audiences it
remains to be seen if talk to me will
boast the same hysteria and
unprecedented reaction regardless with
the reputation it's built in just the
brief time it's been out chances are
that the cult-like following and mystery
surrounding talk to me will only grow
foreign
[Music]